les russes avancent difficilement mais
il avance où en est-on cent jours après
le début de l'invasion russe en ukraine
et bien c'est le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky qui là qu'il l'a dit
les russes contrôlent désormais plus de
125 mille kilomètres carrés de
territoire ukrainien 20% de la
superficie totale on la voit cette zone
de contrôle russe s'est lassé la zone
qui en rouge bordeaux ici incluant la
crimée juste pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée c'est plus que la superficie du
portugal c'est la moitié du royaume uni
c'est à peu près la taille d'un pays
comme la grèce alors on voit les eaux
pendant les premières semaines de ce
conflit l'armée russe a essayé de
s'approcher de kiev s'est lassé les
hommes en gris ici au nord et la pointe
au sud elles ont reflué elle se
concentre maintenant depuis plusieurs
semaines on l'a dit on en parle tous les
jours sur le dombass alors je vous
propose de zoomer sur cette région on va
voir d'une une autre carte s'afficher
pour les le front précisément dans le
donbass donc voilà l'armée russe
enveloppe les villes jumelles de
severodonezk elie sheets lee si j'en ce
pardon chez un petit peu fatiguée elle
les enveloppes 1 par le nord et par
l'est la prise de ces villes
représenterait le contrôle total pour
les russes et les séparatistes de la
région administrative de louhansk ce qui
ferait correspondre la république
autoproclamée des séparatistes au
département ukrainien tel qu'il est et
on a une deuxième colonne russe qui
avant cette fois vers le nord et qui
s'approche de la ville de snow viande ce
que dont on a eu un ordre d'évacuation
et le temps estiment désormais que c'est
une guerre d'usure à laquelle il faut se
préparer sur le long terme tout à fait
alors une guerre d'usure une guerre
d'attrition une guerre de siège tout ça
ça veut dire la même chose pour se
rendre compte un petit peu des effectifs
en 13 ans il ya entre 40 et 60 mille
soldats russes pour à peu près 25 mille
soldats ukrainien c'est un rapport de un
soldat ukrainien pour deux soldats
russes donc dit comme ça on pourrait se
dire que l'armée ukrainienne est en
grande difficulté sauf que dans les
traités militaire
l'idéal pour un assaillant c'est d'avoir
un rapport de 3 contre 1 c'est ce qui
explique aussi pourquoi les les
ukrainiens peuvent résister à ce point
là cela étant l'armée russe l avance est
ce que ce qui se passe au donbass et
sera on le voit en ces destructions de
villes comme c'est le cas c'est les
redonnaise comme ça a été le cas à
marioupol c'est parce qu'il s'agit d'une
guerre basé est centré autour de
l'artillerie la stratégie russe c'est
d'envoyer un tapis d'artillerie de de
saturer les lignes ukrainienne pour les
désorganiser de faire des tirs qui sont
deux des tirs de zones qui sont non
précis d'où les 10 rue des les
destructions dans les villes et les
morts de civils en revanche la stratégie
côté ukrainien avec l'artillerie c'est
le ride and seek c'est à dire de ceux de
se cacher de rechercher une cible de
tirs et précisément et de bouger et
c'est pour ça que l'armée ukrainienne
demande aux occidentaux des équipements
très très précis il est allé canon
caesar français qui sont montés sur
camions et donc qu'ils peuvent bouger il
y aller les pareil les canons m 777
britanniques qui sont montés sur trépied
et il y à cette semaine joe biden qui a
annoncé l'envoi d'un système de
roquettes multiples qui s'appelle le
n140 de hay mars et qui lui aussi est
montés sur camions cette guerre
d'artillerie figurez-vous que à l'état
major en france on la suit avec une
grande attention pourquoi parce qu'il ya
un rapport de la direction générale de
l'armement ici qu il pointe du doigt le
fait que finalement en france on manque
de munitions on parle de 100 milles au
but par jour en ukraine et donc dans les
finances pour l'armée pour le l'année à
venir un qui sont toujours recalculé aux
marges en fonction des événements dans
le monde il y a très précisément une
demande d'augmenter la production des
munitions et d'ailleurs il ya un rapport
parlementaire français qui date du mois
de février qui dit et là je le cite que
en cas de conflit de haute intensité
comme ce qui se passe en ukraine l'armée
française tiendra à peu près une semaine
merci beaucoup bilal tard abeilles pour
m